this is the jonco underground podcast
number 87 sitting with Echo Charles and
me my name is
Joo here's something that can help
you it can actually help you a lot in
life try not to have an opinion on every
freaking thing this is this is a just
put this in your
brain cuz so many people and this is an
easy trend to fall into so many people
have an opinion on
everything they got an opinion on
politics they got an opinion on American
politics they got an opinion on foreign
politics they got an opinion on Sports
they got an opinion on food they got
opinion on diet they got opinion on
working out they got opinion on
everything and I'm talking like a strong
opinion that they're arguing with other
people
about how what do you actually know
about any of this stuff right what do
you actually know what do you you
actually know that you have this big
opinion that you formulated this big
giant
opinion what do you actually know about
that like they they have an opinion
about all these things in the world then
they also have a big opinion about
something going on at work now maybe
they do know more about what's going on
about work but is it really you know
this this new plan at work you got this
big opinion about it no one's tried it
yet the plan hasn't been executed it's
just an idea and you have a big giant
opinion about it and it's letting you
it's your opinion is affecting your
emotions it's affecting your attitude
it's affecting your your
mindset so you have this big opinion
about all these different things and by
the way at work you got an opinion about
Fred right you've got an opinion about
Fred and what he should do and what he
shouldn't do and why he should do it or
why he shouldn't have done it you have a
big opinion about
that and by the way Jessica who's
involved with Fred that we know about
you got to a big opinion on that right
because of course you do cuz you got to
under you're thinking about it you think
it matters you think your opinion about
Fred and Jessica and what they've got
going on you got a big opinion about
that and for some reason at this
juncture in time and and you know what
maybe it's always been this way I'm not
sure but it certainly seems like people
are over opinionated right now and
here's what here's the thing that you
got to watch out for the stronger
opinion that you have the less that you
know I'll say that again in case you
missed it the stronger opinion you have
the less you know and by the way if
you're talking to me with your big
opinion I know that the bigger opinion
you is the less you the bigger opinion
you have the less you actually know
about what you're talking
about because if you really know a lot
you realize there's nuances if you
really know a lot you realize it's like
someone that has a big opinion about a
position in
Jiu-Jitsu when it's like well someone
that actually knows a lot of Jiu Jitsu
goes well there's another way to do that
there's another way and there's thing
that counters that you also got to be
careful of this and also in MMA it
doesn't transfer very well there's
there's a whole there a person that
knows more in Jiu-Jitsu has a more open
mind than someone that's a blue belt
instructor and they're like no you got
to do it this way no actually that's not
completely untrue I mean sorry that's
completely untrue you don't need to do
it that way with there's a point when
someone in Jiu-Jitsu as an instructor
there's a point when people start going
yeah
for me this works
well for other people this is not a
great move there's a previous point a
less mature point where it's like this
is the way you do the move yeah that's a
less knowledgeable person less opinion
more knowledge more opinion less
knowledge
so
the more opinionated you are the less
you listen the less you learn the less
you know and by the way the less time
you spend arguing over stupid things the
more time you spend understanding them
what's better to understand something or
or to argue about it it's better to
increase your understanding of
something but you got a big opinion
about everything about things that are
so complex and so complicated that there
are people that study those subjects for
their entire lives and they don't have
them figured out and yet you do cuz you
watched a YouTube video or cuz you read
two books on the subject if you read
four books on the subject you're going
to realize that oh the first two books
that I read on that subject indicated
this then the next book actually
countered that and the next one
countered it even
further so even the people that write
books on this subject can't agree to
what's correct and what's not
correct but you
do you you do
you know for a
fact cuz you want to have this big
opinion because the big opinion makes
you feel like you know something when in
fact you
don't and and you end up in DG dumb
arguments and you end up saying dumb
things and you're not helping the team
you're not helping the mission you're
not helping your community you're not
helping your
family by the way how well when you when
you attack someone with your big opinion
how does that impact them does it make
them say oh thanks you feel strongly
about this you must be right no they say
you feel so strongly about this that
you're blind to the facts or you're
blind to this other perspective that's
what they
think so instead of going into the world
with this big giant opinion which by the
way just is a reflection of your big
giant ego Instead try try consciously to
actually not have a big giant opinion
about everything
instead of saying you know I think or in
my humble opinion instead of saying
that say you know I've never really
thought about that perspective before
say try saying
that try saying that or try and say you
know that's that's out of the scope of
my knowledge but that's very interesting
hadn't heard that before try saying that
or try saying something as as rare to
leave the human mouth as I'm not sure or
I don't know or I have no
idea and if you can say those things if
you can say I'm not sure or I don't know
your mind will actually open
up your mind will actually open up and
then you can learn and you can find
areas of agreement and then you can have
actual discussions with people
open-minded discussions with
people and that will allow you to become
a better more productive and more useful
human
being instead of
just a person with a big
ego and a big
opinion so there you go just a different
way to approach things could be useful
for
you
y obviously I'm not going to sit here
and say I'm never guilty of that
scenario however though it is is it it
sometimes can be one of those things if
not every time one of those things where
it's super easy when you see someone
else doing this oh yeah and you know and
it's also super easy for you to miss
when you do it you know kind of a thing
but okay let's that being
said it is one of those things if you
can kind of reflect on yourself you'll
notice that there's going to be a big
question mark As to like what what are
we trying to get out of this whole thing
and I know this scenario quite well I
think because I run into it from time to
time where it's you can almost sense
that the person is maybe trying to
express how smart they are or Express
their knowledge you know and impress you
kind of a thing y like I know this much
and and kind of sometimes it can come
down to like hey I'm I'm smarter than
you like that's kind of the underline
message you know I'm smarter than you um
but I don't think it ever can land like
that that there you know like oh sh if
someone's doing it to you it's it's
unlikely you're going to end up with the
idea like oh damn you're you're so smart
you know when you have this huge like
fired up opinion or whatever it's more
you're probably going to leave the
person
with that guy sounds kind of ignorant
you know like he got all fired up bro
it's not even that serious you know kind
of a thing like none of us know about
this
stuff it's weird that you can develop
such a strong opinion on things that are
so unsure yeah like things that are
things that are unknown like I said a
real obvious example is like a plan to
do something yeah you know like a
mission or a project that you've got M
and Echo comes to
me that is a little excerpt of what we
are doing on the Joo underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jo underground.com and sub subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it cost
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo ground.com and
we'll get you taken care of until then
we will see you
mobilized
Underground